hey it's tyler from big brother all
stars
and this is my e.t post eviction
interview
by a vote of three to zero
tyler you are evicted from the big
brother house
where do i think my game went wrong who
i don't know
there's a lot of moments that i could
probably pinpoint
but that would take a while um
i can't really say a direct moment in
time
i definitely know at the beginning it
took me a while to really get in
the big brother's zone if that makes
sense like my first season i felt like i
was dialed in from
minute one but this time it took me a
while
so maybe that uh beginning part of the
game
uh i wasn't really setting myself up as
well as i could have
but i have no regrets tyler i also have
a final three
with cody enzo and myself and a final
three
with me enzo and christmas but it has
been a true
pleasure playing this game with you tai
what you
definitely probably could assume i have
a final two with nicole and i have a
final two with
enzo what you probably didn't assume is
that since the beginning of this game
on the second day i created a final two
with memphis called the commission
yeah those guys had all the final twos
sounded like me from big brother 20.
um no i definitely think it was a good a
good move to reveal that
to me at least um i think it's a good
strategy
and i think it's gonna make for some
good tv
coming down the line because this end
game is gonna be messy
they're gonna have to pick and choose
and i'm excited to see
oh which house gets left has done the
worst job of jury management
i gotta say christmas because
pretty sure she was like yelling at
danny
as she was walking out the door so
i gotta say christmas is not doing the
best job with jury management and that's
why i wanted to sit next to her in the
final two
but who knows she could be giving the
world's best
goodbye messages i don't know but to me
it seemed like she was not doing that
great
of a job
no i don't think i would have evicted
anybody other than danny
i had been setting it up for weeks uh
letting everybody know like hey
danny's being sketchy i need her to go
i don't trust her so if i would have
done anything else
they would have all told danny if she
stuck around and
it just would not have made sense so no
i wouldn't have done anything different
i'm a competitor and i love this game so
much
like i i want to stand for something
bigger
if that makes sense i see how bad you
want to be here
and i feel guilty and like i don't want
to take
that away from either you guys i was one
million percent
genuine in that because like i said
it took me a while to really get into
the game
and play big brother the way it should
be played
because i had so much on my mind about
wanting to do the right thing
wanting the right people to be
successful and
when they ended up on the block together
and i felt like it was my fault i felt
so
guilty that i could have possibly
prevented it and i did it so i was
one million percent being genuine with
that and
christmas kind of had to like knock some
game sense into me
and be like listen i can't backdoor you
you are my final two
like that would make no sense and from
there i kind of had to
turn on big brother mode and keep
playing because that's what i was there
for
but i was one million percent genuine i
would have absolutely
sacrificed my own game for them
my message to angela only
three weeks left i cannot wait to see
her face
and just never ever be away
again for this long i love you so much
[Music]
angela
you